one of my personal favorite
existentialist thinkers is somebody
who's not all that well-known in part I
think because his works and his
importance to the whole is kind of
fallen through certain cracks there's a
whole long story there that we could go
into perhaps in another video and this
guy's name is lab chest off sometimes
you'll see him written with a c CH
instead of an SH sometimes it's lay on
or lay oh he's a Russian author yeah
from a Jewish background he has a lot in
common with Kierkegaard but also in many
respects with Nietzsche and with
Dostoevsky and he's one of the first
people to actually pull their thought
together into something termed
existential thought existentialism and
the book that we're going to start out
with first because I'm going to do quite
a few of his works the English
translation that I'm using is called all
things are possible the Russian title
for it hope I'm getting this right is
Apple feyo's des Pope vanity which
literally means the apotheosis of
groundlessness the lack of of an
ultimate ground beneath your feet
beneath things and that really does fit
is a title the central theme of this
work and of chefs toes work in general
so I want to in this first video I'm
going to touch on just a few themes that
are coming out in this work and I'm
going to be jumping around quite a bit
in the work in part because chef stuff
is like it was here he's an anti
systemic thinker
now that means two different things with
respect to chef start one is he is
attacking the very notion of system not
in the way that some anti-systemic
thinkers do or they all systematizing is
wrong
it's rather you saying well you can do
that sort of thing if you like but it's
not gonna work out for you the
you would like it to you're actually
imposing that upon yourself and while
the system may actually be good for
certain things it's not going to
alternate Lee get you to what you want
and it's going to blind you to a lot of
reality in that respect he's a lot like
Kierkegaard in his approach the system
Kierkegaard was not just trying to bash
the system he's saying it's got holes in
it there's there's parts that are
missing out his actual approach to to
writing itself is going to be
anti-systemic in the sense that chest
off is not going to leave you with a
finished system of philosophy he's
engaged in a lot of sort of filling in
gaps here and there and writing about
this and writing about this and making
connections between things but he's not
going to give you some sort of
architectonic of the whole over all the
different things fit in with each other
and he will range over a number of
different topics he is a very highly
literate author so you need to know a
little bit about some people in order to
make sense of what he's saying because
he throws in a lot of allusions I would
say in some respect the person who he
reminds me of the most is somebody who's
not to connect with existentialism at
all but the critical theory and that
would actually be Theodor Adorno their
works have the same sort of complexity
the same sort of critical stance which
is you know critiquing is not the same
thing as just you know poking holes and
rejecting it's saying well we're kind of
stuck with this but you know what about
this and this and this and so that's
what chef's stuff is doing he's not an
aphoristic author where he's just you
know doing one-liners or an aphorism is
really a two liner he is putting
together coherent paragraphs coherent
sections the same themes emerge over and
over again but there's no effort to try
to bring these together again the essay
on this or the essay on this even when
he has books devoted to something
particularly his later Athens and
Jerusalem it'll be a bunch of connected
essays rather than one systematic whole
one of the key themes that you're gonna
see running throughout his his work is
his attack on our
idolization or being the wildered which
is something that we impose upon
ourselves and and other people posed
upon us by necessity by reason by logic
by morality all these sorts of things
that say it must be this way things can
only work out this way that would
include also the you know the conscient
theory of knowledge and although you
know post catching theories of knowledge
after that we can cons week any sort of
idea that would tell us there's a closed
system and here's the axioms the
principles by which it works and
everything must fit into this he's going
to reject and his grounds for rejecting
it are actually quite interesting we'll
proceed through a lot of those he's
engaged in a critique of philosophy he
is trying to say this is what philosophy
looks like this is what passes for
philosophy and has passed for philosophy
for quite a while this is what
philosophy ought to be like this is what
philosophy could be like this is what
could be going on and he's also a critic
of the culture of modernity in many
respects when you read the things that
he's saying you don't get a sense that
his work is very dated I mean he wrote
in a time before a lot of the
technological advances that we not only
took for granted but have even surpassed
and yet at the same time his work is
completely fresh his discussions of our
attitudes towards technology towards
modern culture towards thinking about
public opinion
all those sorts of things are still
relevant today
what is the advancing he is a great
advocate
the imagination the imagination
outstrips is even Kanu elbow constant
will it out strips it but then it sort
of falls you know to something less than
Rio less than important the imagination
outstrips that the bounds of logic
science of morality of what we all know
of common sense and so you might say
well that sounds awful an awful lot like
the romantics it's just off a romantic
no because he's not celebrating
imagination really for its own sake or
saying what you should always go with it
he's saying well look you know there's a
lot of things that you can't imagine
that just simply don't fit into these
philosophical or logical or scientific
or moral systems very well and there are
you know if you if you care about these
sorts of things these are you know real
important there's some goodness there
there's some beauty there there's some
you know truth there yeah and so you
need to give that it's do you need to
find a space for it or carve out a space
for it or push through the things you
know maybe if we want to use the iron
cage of rationality that mocks Weber
talked about maybe you need to bend the
bars a bit or maybe you need to get a
imaginative jaws of life in there and
you know crimp it open a bit freedom
there's a real recognition of the value
of freedom not in the abstract but
indeterminate circumstances in dealing
with one's own life possibility there
are always possibilities that are being
unrealizable
and that's particularly important for
him we never want to close off the
bounds of possibility and say well this
is simply impossible
well we're tempted to do that all the
time and then finally I have up here
laughing and crying chefs Toph thinks
that one of the things that the
take Spinoza as being sort of a classic
example of this has been left out in
philosophy are these limit conditions
laughing and crying those are so
integral to the human condition -
everybody's condition not just the
philosophers but everybody something is
revealed in laughter something is
revealed in tears in sorrow in joy in
humor and we need to explore that he
thinks we need to actually take that as
seriously as we would a logical proof or
a metaphysical system what else he is
one of the first people like I mentioned
to bring together Kierkegaard Nietzsche
and Dostoevsky I think that for its own
sake justify as talking about chest off
but he's not just noting a connection
between those so he's not just a
historian of philosophy saying yeah
there's this existential philosophy
going on here are three of the guys that
are involved with it by the way he
didn't actually think it was just three
he's interested in Tolstoy as well and
in check off and in a few other figures
who he thinks fit in there but those are
the big three
and what he does is he draws on their
works from time to time in a very
critical manner he does not entirely
endorse what Kierkegaard is doing he
does not entirely endorse what
Nietzsche's doing sometimes and it's
very interesting you would expect a
religious thinker to always take
Kierkegaard side against Nietzsche he
doesn't always do that Dostoevsky some
really important things going on in
Dostoyevsky's work and then he also
criticizes him for taking on the role of
a prophet as we'll talk about in another
video or actually in several videos
later on one of the things that he's
doing I think you know to say there's
there's one central move
that's chest obeah it's putting out
mistaken assumptions that do seem to
make sense at the time but if you were
to reflect and think about you'd say
well it's not as
definite not as necessary not as cut and
dry as we thought when you consider to
the larger sphere of life maybe I
shouldn't go so far with making
assumptions and turning this in just
like a whole philosophical worldview
that then imports things like you know
necessity reason morality the entire
sort of iron cage again if we want to
use the Bavarian phrase and makes that
what a person imprisons themselves with
them and other people and their their
engagements with other people and their
imagination and we could go on and on so
he's good at pointing out these sort of
mistaken assumptions and what we're
going to do in in some respect is in
going through his work is just sort of
jump through and there are several
different major themes that I want to
pick up on but you're going to find them
scattered all throughout this this work
of his this all things are possible
because he writes it in terms of
numbered sections or paragraphs some of
them are only a few sentences some of
them are several pages and they change
from subject to subject there are a few
you know where the same subject is going
through several of these numbered
paragraphs but but he shifts around
quite a bit and you probably could
reorder them in a different number and
they would make just as much sense
because each one is kind of a unit so we
have to look across these different
units and bring together the common
themes the other thing that I will say
is the the copy that I have is rather
hard to come by so I'm actually going to
be reading quite a few passages out of
this verbatim in part because I'm not
going to assume unlike you know say
Nietzsche's genealogy of morals or
characters fear and trembling that you
can easily get your hands on this and I
think that chest off is such a brilliant
writer that he does deserve to have his
words heard pondered over
listen to ruminated upon and so there's
gonna be a mitt perhaps a little bit
less of my own interjection and
synthesizing of his work and a bit more
of just attending to what he's actually
saying because his thought is often
quite quite clear and an interesting for
its own sake so I think a natural
starting point for wading into chef
stops thought in this work in particular
is to begin with looking at two
metaphors and we're going to look at the
one that happens in the second part of
the work first and part cuz it's kind of
a master of metaphor from what he's up
to
always advising us or opening us up to
and the second one has to do with things
that are coming up in the very first
book with with the the metaphor of
streets well we'll get to that in a
moment the first metaphor has to do with
a fish and he it's coming from a section
entitled on method so he says a certain
naturalist made the following experiment
a glass jar was divided into two he
house by a perfectly transparent glass
partition it's a big big jar right on
the one side of the partition he placed
a pike so this is a predatory fish the
top of the food chain in European lakes
and and well they live in the Baltic Sea
but they're not the from the top of the
food chain there and here in the United
States they're not quite the top of the
food chain one of their close relatives
the muskellunge is but they're they're
very dangerous fish to other fish so on
the other side he put small fishes such
as form the prey of the pike the pike
did not notice the partition and rammed
into the partition with the result being
only a bruised nose the same happened
many times and with always with the same
effect and laugh seeing its efforts
ended so painfully the pike abandoned
the hunt so that in a few days and the
partition had been removed it continued
to swim about among the small fry
without daring to attack them so you've
got an experiment going on here
a fairly low level of animal learn
something what does it learn to observe
limits so he says does not the same
happen with us perhaps the limits
between this world and the other world
are also essentially of an experimental
origin so the limits between this world
on the other world when we're doing
philosophy what are we doing are we just
playing with ideas or are we reflecting
at the very same time that we're also
doing where we're experimenting with
life itself with taking risks with
seeing what will happen so he says
perhaps the limits between this world
and the other world are also essentially
of an experimental origin
neither rooted in the nature of things
as we thought before can't so a lot of
philosophers had conceptions of the very
nature of things they have to be this
way this is this is the set of logical
possibilities nothing else exists
besides that carries out a Copernican
revolution and going away from the
object to the subject whose knowing the
object and projecting you might say the
very reality the categories of
possibility upon it and he says perhaps
neither rooted in the nature of things
as was thought before cut or in the
nature of our reason as is thought after
can't perhaps indeed a partition does
exist between this world and the other
world appearance in reality pick
whatever you like
it does make vain all attempts to cross
over but perhaps there comes a moment
when the partition is removed in our
minds however the conviction is firmly
rooted that it is impossible to pass
certain limits and painful to try a
conviction founded on our experience so
it is rooted in experience but the
question is can we extrapolate from what
we have experienced to say it will
always be this way we can generalize and
even universal eyes so he says in this
case we should recall the old skeptic
system of Hume which idealist philosophy
is regard as the mirror subtle mind play
valueless after Kant's critique Kant's
critique of Hume the most lasting and
varied experience cannot lead to any
binding and universal conclusion that
was Humes point that we do in fact have
a basis of experience upon which we rely
and we do in fact construct the way we
think things work and our general ideas
on the basis of that experience but our
experience could always be somewhat
different so we could have arrived at
other rules of their regularities other
ways of understanding things we can't
entirely place confidence in our the
fruits of our experience so it says no
all our priori all of our sort of having
decided it ahead of time it must be this
way which are so useful for a certain
time become sooner or later extremely
harmful this is worth dwelling upon
chef's table is not saying I get rid of
experience altogether don't don't ever
generalize never make judgments as a
matter of fact if you're gonna do that
you'd be insane or you would be living a
very very comfortable closeted cocooned
lifestyle that somebody else is making
possible which is you know the case of
quite a few people in late modernity in
certain ways you have to make judgments
you have to actually draw inferences you
have to project out ahead of you certain
structures but you shouldn't think that
those a priori structures are always
going to hold you shouldn't use them as
a sort of infallible guide to what could
possibly be the case like he says a
philosopher should not be afraid of
skepticism but should go on bruising his
jaw the philosophers the pike the pike
should keep hitting that partition even
though it's going to lead to pain it's
going to lead to embarrassment it's
going to lead to ignominy it's going to
lead to people saying what the hell are
you doing you should know better than
that
because sometime that partition may in
fact
now and unless you're actually pushing
you won't know that it's come down if
you said I know where the partition is
it's it's it's a limit I have to observe
it I can never get past it well then you
will never push on it and you will never
get through when the partition actually
does come down he says perhaps at the
very moment when man ceased his painful
pursuit settled all those questions and
rested on his laurels in nerd if he
could have with one strong push have
swept through the pernicious fence was
separated him from the unknowable there
is no need for man to move according to
a carefully considered plan this is a
perfectly ascetic demand which need not
bind us let me in senselessly and
deliriously knock his head against the
wall if the wall go down at last well he
value is triumph any the less
unfortunately for us the illusion has
been established that that plan and
purpose are the best guarantee of
success what a delusion it is the
opposite is true the best of all that
genius has revealed to us has been
revealed as the result of fantastic
erratic apparently ridiculous and
useless but relentlessly stubborn
seeking so he's setting out for us
a sort of Kierkegaard Ian passionate
commitment as a way of life he's he's
transforming what other people would
call radical empiricism into a motive of
doing philosophy and as a way of life as
well
so now I'm going to talk about this
metaphor of streets which is very
similar to this he says and is the very
beginning of his work in part one the
obscure streets of life do not offer the
conveniences of the central
thoroughfares
no electric light no gas not even a
kerosene lamp bracket there are no
pavements the traveler has to fumble his
way in the dark if he needs a light he
must wait for a thunderbolt or else
primitive wise not a spark out of the
stone in a glimpse will appear
familiar outlines and then what he has
taken in he must try to remember no
matter whether the impression was right
or false for you will not easily get
another light unless he run his head
against the wall and see sparks that way
what can a wretched pedestrian gather
under circles such circumstances how can
we expect a clear account from him whose
curiosity led him to grope his way along
among the outskirts of life why should
we try to compare his records with those
of travelers through brilliant streets
this is a great metaphor the things that
really matter to us that a lot of people
just haven't thought about we don't have
the methods we don't have the the
thoroughfares plotted out quite so well
they're not as brightly lit if lit at
all we have to bring our own light to it
this is sort of like almost the opposite
of Plato's Plato's allegory of the cave
isn't it with the cave you you leave a
portion of some light - much greater
light and it all makes perfect sense
after your eyes adjust to it with this
he's saying boy you'd better develop
some night vision because you are going
to need it when you're trying to make
sense of things that other people have
not plumbed but which are equally real
that are uncharted but equally valid
equally true that you actually
experience think about you know trying
to reflect upon your own life condition
sort of things that existentialism is is
continually focusing upon it's not quite
so easy you know there's this old joke
about the guy who is in the middle of
the street and he's under a streetlight
and he's looking and the cop comes along
and says what are you doing there buddy
and he says looking for my watch and the
cop says did you lose it in this this
spot light and he says no I lost it over
there in the dark and the cop says well
what are you doing over here that this
is not the place where you're gonna
fight he says well the light is so much
better over here I think I've got a
better chance of finding it there are
many things which
are over there in the in the dark in the
penumbra but you know the twilight
between light and dark or there in the
the inky blackness and we have to exert
ourselves to find them notice with this
metaphor though there are streets it's
not as if nobody has ever traveled this
before that's a key thing to this now
this comes up again in section 33 where
he says the possibilities which open it
up before mankind are sufficiently
limited it is impossible to see
everything impossible to know everything
impossible to rise to high above the
earth impossible to penetrate too deeply
down what has been is hidden away what
will be we cannot anticipate and we know
for certain we shall never grow wings
regularity immutably regular succession
of phenomena puts a term to all of our
efforts drives us into a regular narrow
hard beaten road here's the metaphor of
everyday life but even on this road we
may not wander too much from side to
side we must watch our feet consider
every step since the moment we're off
our guard disaster is upon us there's
more to this and I'm going to come back
to that in a moment but let's dwell on
so the notion is look we can't know very
much about things because of temporality
because of the scope of a human life and
we're better off just sticking with what
we what we do know what other people
have plotted out what what is sort of
for certain but even with that we have
to watch ourselves there the roads are
there but we can stumble off with them
fall into the ditch wind up in the
meadow over there all together end up
getting lost in the forest we have to
keep ourselves on it now he sketches out
another possibility he says another life
is conceivable this goes back to this
all things are possible another life is
conceivable life in which the word
disaster does not exist
we're responsibility for one's own
actions even if it be not completely
abolished
lise is not such a deadly an accidental
weight and we're on the other hand there
is no regularity but rather an infinite
number of possibilities and such a life
the sense of fear most disgraceful to us
disappears there the virtues are not the
same as ours fearlessness in the face of
danger liberality even lavishness are
considered virtues with us but they are
respected without any grounds
fearlessness and lavish mr. nut suit
mortal men rather it becomes them to
tremble and count every penny that's why
those two virtues are so rarely met with
he says and he starts going into a lot
of other discussions but now think about
this for a moment are these two
metaphors connected they are him hidden
skepticism was about thinking about what
was possible the reason why the things
that have become habitual taken for
granted you know part of our social
matrix the I you know the aa priori with
which we surround ourselves which we
inherit which we internalize all those
sorts of things that bind us and say no
it can only go this way or this way
there is no other possibility or this
way this way this way no fourth
possibility all of those things are
coming about as a result of
extrapolating from the limited
experience we have over here which has
been fairly regular and saying it's all
like that when we know that's not
necessarily the case because we can
conceive of something different if we
can this Humes point if we can conceive
of something different even if it
doesn't exist then we know that this
does not exhaust the scope of logical
possibilities there's this over here and
if there's this over here I'll bet you
there's something else over here and
something else over here and then this
starts to shake and we start saying well
I guess now this is
cut-and-dried as we as we had thought so
if that's the case that means that him
was they actually historically
exhibiting a kind of failure of nerve in
comparison to somebody like like chef
stuff why do I say that because Hume
said well we do have regularity that we
can remain within and rely upon when it
came to matters of for example religion
well we just use this in a destructive
way so that we don't actually have to
believe in anything because that's all
inconceivable when really there's all
sorts of possibilities that you know
could have been sort of culled out from
a human position
likewise with respect to society Hume
says well human beings are more or less
the same in nature throughout history
across cultures when really if he had
been you know following through on his
own principles he would have been you
know more likely to say oh this stuff we
can't actually take for granted so so
easily there are other possibilities
because look there's one over there and
there's one over there so chest off is
is doing something with human ideas
really not just human ideas many other
people thought he's doing something that
Hume himself didn't do so these these
are tied together he's telling us about
what we ought to be doing and doing
philosophies so there are some other
passages that I think are very relevant
to this this particular theme so I'm
gonna go through a number of these part
1 section 9 he says we know nothing of
the ultimate realities of our existence
nor shall we ever know anything let that
be agreed it doesn't mean that he's
actually committed to that it says but
it does not follow therefore that we
must accept some or other dogmatic
theory as a modus vivendi
no not even positivism which he has such
a skeptical face on it it only follows
here's where we get to the shastovich
philosophy that man is free to change
his conception of the universe as often
as he changes his boots or and/or his
gloves and that constancy of principle
belongs only
one's relationships with other people
I'm gonna say that one more time
constancy of principle belongs only to
one's relationships with other people in
order that they may know where and to
what extent they may depend on us that's
that's a that comes up over and over
again and chest off morality necessity
logic all these sorts of things are not
absolute constants the way that they're
portrayed to be they don't govern the
entire very structure of the universe
you know making it so that they things
can only be this way or this way or this
way the things that we rely upon in
order to live with other people in order
to be able to sort of make it you might
say another good passage he says that
philosophy must have nothing in common
with logic philosophy is an art that
aims at breaking the logical continuity
of argument and bringing man out of the
shoreless sea of imagination so there's
this big disjunction between philosophy
as it is and philosophy as it could be
as it ought to be as would be more
freeing for us more fun even for us so
he says the fantastic times where
everything is equally possible it
impossible certainly it's difficult
given sedentary habits of life to be a
good philosopher the fact that the fate
of philosophy has ever laid in the hands
of professors can only be explained by
the reluctance of the envious gods to
give emissions to mortals so you know
the fact that philosophy professors like
myself included and I do a live a very
sedentary life are the ones who are
teaching it who are you know inducting
people into it that's a that's not a
necessarily a bad thing in in the moral
sense of chef's stuff but it's a
limiting constraining thing again we see
that philosophy you know for the
existentialist is really about something
lived something vital something visceral
a little bit later section 66 he says in
the ultimate questions
life we are not a bit nearer the truth
than their ancestors were everybody
knows it yet so many go on talking about
infinity without any hope of ever saying
anything it is evident that a result in
the usual acceptance of the word is not
necessary in the very last resort we
trust instinct even in the field of
philosophy where reason is supposed to
reign supreme
uttering its eternal why why laughs at
all possible because --is instinct ogre
does not mock it simply ignores the whys
and leads us on by impossible waves to
ends that are divine reason would hold
absurd if it could only see them in time
but reason is a laggard without much
foresight and therefore when we run up
to an unexpected conclusion nothing
remains but for reason to accept or even
to justify to exalt the new event
therefore reality is reasonable say the
Philosopher's what is he saying here
he's saying reason is kind of an
imperfect tool it's always a little bit
behind what is going on with life what
is going on where our instincts are
leading us where philosophy itself as a
procedure as a process as an activity
has gone he advises that we take upon
doubt as something that we incorporate
into our very way of philosophizing he
says we should undertake doubt seriously
not in order to return at length to
establish beliefs where that would be a
vicious circle so he's not saying let's
doubt like Descartes did I'm gonna strip
everything away or even who Cyril did a
little bit later on he's not responding
to Crystal but he this would apply to
question was Cartesian entity I'm gonna
bracket everything and then I'll bring
everything back just how it is only a
little bit brighter no why should we
doubt doubt has a more positive effect
than that he thinks he says experience
shows us that such a process only leads
from era to era we should doubt so that
doubt becomes a continuous creative
force inspiring the very essence of our
life for
established knowledge argues in us a
condition of imperfect receptivity so
doubting itself can become something
that bears out positive results when we
actually doubt we are opening ourselves
up for possibility we are traveling
perhaps down these roads that we haven't
done before we are seeing whether the
barrier actually still stands in place
he says in another place this is a
section 101 every philosophic world
conception starts from one or other
solution of the general problem of human
existence and proceeds from this to
direct the course of human life in some
particular direction or another this is
actually worth sort of mapping out what
he's what he's saying here every single
philosophical orientation and if he's
being honest he would actually have to
include his own in this so every
philosophical world conception starts
from one solution of the general problem
of human existence
we're posed with sort of general issues
that we all have to grapple with death
life birth taxes even to a certain
extent how to live with other people
what to do with our anger when to cry
when to laugh when to son to present
when to say no all these sorts of things
am i a good person am i a bad person
what should I have done was my life a
mistake should i triumphed at this point
these are all parts of the general
problem of human existence why do we
suffer why do they suffer is there a god
isn't there a God
all of these lead us to adopt
philosophical world conceptions these
then direct the course of human life
what does he mean by that well they can
direct the course of an individual human
life you know you start out with your
individual situation and you realize
that you're not the only person to face
it you're in pain all the time your life
is a veil of suffering in tears now you
come to some sort of philosophical world
conception well we were put on this
earth to suffer that is the highest
thing that we can we can possibly have
nothing is going to get better than that
but there's a consolation in the
suffering having more suffering than
other people makes me stand out
being able to endure it shows me that I
have a certain dignity that other people
are lacking now I actually seek out
occasions for suffering is you know sort
of a mistaken view of stoicism or even a
kind of sentimentalism but people do
trap themselves in that you know start
out with different general problems of
human existence how can we actually get
along with each other
given the fact that we don't see eye to
eye on so many basic things not even
likewhat fairness is but what even
counts as human goodness well maybe we
need to adopt something like the liberal
democratic point of view where we all
just sort of you know agree to disagree
so long as we don't break the basic
rules of the society and we keep moving
in a fairly progressive direction
incorporating more and more people into
this John wall's into the the community
of you know people who are granted
dignity and treated with respect
then I should act in certain ways so I
should support for example amendments
about gay marriage
you know the Bears out in particular
life whereas if I start from other
starting points maybe I don't arrive at
that sort of course of human life I
don't arrive at those kinds of decisions
maybe you know if you go that way I
devote myself to Animal Liberation ala
Peter Singer or something like that the
general problem of human existence is
something like how can I come to know
the truth about the universe other
philosophical world consumptions are
more congenial to that they lead to if
we're being consistent other forms of
life and now notice that we've been
talking about individuals this can also
apply to you know families clubs
organizations schools societies in which
each one is still an individual trying
to work out their own issues and ideas
and things like that but we do this
collectively as well we come up with
culture cultures differ from each other
because cultures are working with
different philosophical world
conceptions because cultures are
grappling with different sets of general
problems of human existence to which
they give a higher priority to some and
a lesser to others so he says we have
neither the power nor the data for the
solution of general problems so our
moral deductions are arbitrary they only
witness to our prejudices if we're
naturally
to our propensity isn't Asaph were
self-confident but to keep up prejudices
is a miserable unworthy business let's
seize he says to grieve about our
differences in opinions let us wish that
in the future there should be many more
differences and much less Union
unanimity there is no arbitrary truth
that's a beautiful thing he says there
there's no arbitrary truth
it remains to suppose that truth lies
and changeable human tastes and desires
what is he saying there we have to seek
truth where people are actually living
out some sort of truth we can't assume
that it's just going to be arbitrarily
assumed from above odd to everybody
is this just hardcore and you know
making an excuse for everybody
relativism no because there are certain
forms of life that are just going to be
like totally self-defeating and you know
even people who adopt a relativist
perspective is a chef's stuff we'll talk
about it eventually get disgusted with
themselves and the separate things that
they're they're saying are okay so it
doesn't go quite so far as there let's
look a little bit further ahead again we
talked about what it is to be a
philosopher what it is to to to live out
the life of philosophy says to think
really to think surely this for me this
means a relinquish ik relinquishing of
this notion that there are laws of
thought that actually we've discovered
and they govern all thought they
constrain all possibilities it means
living a new life it means a permanent
sacrifice this isn't a CSIS the dearest
habits taste attachments without even
assurance that the sacrifice will bring
any compensation
it's interesting you know you think
about the the pike again busting its
nose on the glass you do never know
whether the partition will come down it
could not come down ever during your
lifetime and you only get your lifetime
to do it but unless you keep bumping
your nose on the glass
you won't know whether it does come down
that means a sort of ascetic
commitment to stripping yourself of the
the the witching power Oh like he says
dearest habits taste attachments says
artisan philosophers like to imagine the
thinker with a stern face a profound
look which penetrates into the unseen a
noble bearing and a you'll preparing for
flight some like this not at all this is
a wonderful phrase that he says here a
thinking man is a man who has lost his
balance in the vulgar not in the tragic
sense there's nothing dignified about it
hams raking the air feet flying they
scared and bewildered he is a caricature
of helplessness and pitiable perplexity
that's what it is to think when do we
actually us human beings when do we
begin to really think in a full sense
that's when we tripped and were
off-balance and holy crap I better
figure something out quick
that's what which ésta thinks life is
really composed of and you know can you
manufacture those sorts of occasions I
suppose you can throw people into
situations that are supposed to provoke
that sort of thing but but no you can't
the good news is however life will throw
you enough of those curveballs you will
trip over enough rocks as you're walking
down the street then you will have
plenty of opportunity to indulge
yourself in that sort of thing going on
a little bit further but I'm going to
come back to that one because that's a
wonderful quote he says there are no
unit all binding universal judgments
let's manage with non-binding
non-universal ones we don't have to stop
thinking we don't have to stop saying
that some things are you know given
taken for granted that we can rely
let's just not think that they are
always going to be the case and that we
can treat them as if they as if they are
he talks about the need to open a free
road to the passions even in the
province of metaphysics we need to
experience more we need to trust our our
feelings our emotions more and then
finally that here's the passage that I
wanted to close this section with he
advocates this he says the best way of
getting rid of tedious played-out truths
is to stop paying them the tribute of
respect and treat them with a touch of
easy familiarity and division to put
into brackets as Dostoevsky did such
words as good self-sacrifice progress
and so on will alone achieve you so much
more than many brilliant arguments would
do why while you can test a certain
truth you still believe in it and this
even the least penetrating individual
will believe but if you favor it with no
serious attention and only throw out a
scornful remark now and then the result
is different it's evident you cease to
be afraid of the old truth you no longer
respect it and this sets people thinking
this is a very interesting thing to say
particularly in our own as some people
want to call it post modern times I
myself find that so many people who want
to call themselves post modernists or
critical theorists or you know
genealogists pick whatever you like
whether they're the these or Waterdown
psychoanalytic type because there is a
really great psychoanalysis out there
but these people don't often do that the
Marxist type the the Nietzschean type
the Foucauldian type very often these
people are prisoners a kind of Dogma a
morality that they're attacking you know
and other people all the time
and they don't realize that that they're
doing it chest off was ahead of
third time the present or whatever it is
that they think is the present back a
hundred years ago more than a hundred
years ago was written in 1905 so I'm
going to put this on the board
he says it's talking about tedious out
truths best way is not to give them
respect nor is it to contest to protest
to critique rather it's to be an easy
familiarity one of the things that
that's kind of interesting to think
about is you know you hear all these
people talking about the end of
metaphysics and deconstruction and you
know post-modernism and irony and
bricolage and pastiche and all these
sorts of things and are they really
having an easy familiarity with it or
are they still respecting still
contesting their attitude so often
there's not a lot that's fun that's
light-hearted about their there their
effect
and chefs talk is a person like I just
said it who thinks that a fact is
something we want to take into account
when we're doing metaphysics Danny's
getting from Kierkegaard that he's
getting from Nietzsche that he's
actually getting from Dostoevsky because
our emotional sight is just as important
as our logical or rational side I think
that a lot of people who think that
they're treating tedious played-out
truths with easy familiarity have really
turned it into something more like a
battle to the death or you know
something that their ego is invested in
or you might say they turned it into
kind of a commodity process we all get
together
in read Nietzsche and talk about how
Nietzsche was the last minute position
although Heidegger and how we're gonna
get past him and we don't want to be the
humor bench because that's not really
nice anymore to talk about that sort of
stuff because I lived with the Nazis and
and all that but we really want to also
deconstruct everything using H over here
the people who get involved in that sort
of stuff
are rarely in my experience and Anna
chef staff would say we do have to rely
on our experience just you know don't
try to make a general catch-all pattern
of it they're not very fun they're not
very joyful in many ways they're not
very neat yet or cure archaea there is
there's that lacking that easy
familiarity he says that we ought to be
able to favor it with no serious
attention only throw out a scornful
scornful remark now on that you know we
should feel the same way about the end
of metaphysics which people take very
very seriously they're always you know
coming up with a new end of metaphysics
as we would about Kant's categories of
the understanding that's a chest off
would say so this actually leads to
another aspect of chef's stuffs thought
that I'm not going to quote any passages
but I would like to talk about when I
said that chest off is committed to a
sense freedom possibility
so a part of this is about overcoming
limits within our lives and a lot
culture now this could be done in a very
sort of ascetic way I'm going to strip
all these things away it could be done
in a very crusading kind of way
everybody must do this everybody who's
living a real life ought to go this way
is how we you know usually get around
the must because must sounds bad work
he'd be done in the way of sort of just
saying here's some possibilities here
are some things to think about things to
consider chef Slav does not impose
himself upon anybody
that's where you know his notion of
critique or what he's doing is very very
different than what a lot of people call
critique if we take Conte as an example
you know the critique of Pure Reason is
supposed to tell us this is what's
possible for pure reason that stuff over
there ain't this stuff over here isn't
even conceivable you've got to stay
within these limits and the good news is
there are limits that you yourself are
imposing on reality so you know you have
some role and it's not just reality
imposing on you but you've got to stay
within these limits and then what
happens you know immediately afterwards
people are like well that's not really a
limit over there but I'm gonna impose
some other limits I'm gonna be even more
critical than cons chef's stuff is not
doing that
chef stuff is not saying you you can't
do this you can't do that he's just
saying look if you do this sort of thing
over here if you commit yourself this
way then this is likely to be the result
will it definitely be the result I don't
know because I don't claim to know
everything and I don't have the
resources of logic or you know reason
that would work with infallible rules to
tell me exactly what's going to happen
because well I think there's probably
going to happen and therefore it's
useful to actually know something about
history so that you know partly you can
recognize older patterns when it comes
to the history of thought you want to be
able to say well I'm falling into the
same thing that Socrates did here or I'm
I'm treating the same path as Nietzsche
going down this way or I'm doing the
same thing as a chef's table so part of
what I really enjoy about chef's stuff
is the fact that he leaves it up to the
reader to figure out what they're going
to do with that what they're gonna make
of his thought each reader I think going
into chef's stuff is going to find
different things that are going to
appeal to them that will resonate with
them that's not to say it'll be a
completely unique experience that when
you're reading chest off it'll be
totally unlike what I'm doing but I
think that chef's table lends himself to
that much better than certain other
thinkers do he made that part of his
very process so to speak so there is a
kind of delightful freedom coming along
with the very reading of chef's stuff
that I think it's one of the great
virtues his work and I think that that's
part of his consistent approach to
things he doesn't compel anybody worry
to do that he would be falling back into
these sort of you know structures and
limits that he's trying to to get out of
so in certain respects chest off is one
of the most existentialist of the
existentialist thinkers and in future
videos I'm going to talk a little bit
more about these themes in this book and
in other books and you'll see this stuff
play itself out